the white sox are back at guaranteed
raid field everybody willing to wait out
a rain delay at least here on day number
one and it is
truly a a remarkable day at guaranteed
rate field and finally we are ready to
play baseball
last last year with a bad ball club was
a very good pitcher so he's given every
indication that he
is in line for a big year this year
their lead off band whitmerfield
and a cut and a miss welcome back sox
fans
serenading a strikeout because it is a
different experience right now and lance
lynn
is mowing down royals two gone in the
first
carlos four for 19. looking for his
first home run as a royal
a guaranteed rate field and lancelin
christens it by striking out the side
yeah let's just hope that brad keller
can get strike one in there and
just keep working ahead but pounding
down in the zone
is what they need from him let's get the
ovation for the reigning mvp
[Applause]
jose abreu in the air right center field
and up the alleyway extra bases for
abreu with
two out here in the first and now johan
monkatta trying to drive him in
johan in the air left center field this
is dawn for the first time in two years
light it up an opposite field two run
bomb on a slider
it was out over the plate we told you
montana had some luck against keller
he puts the socks on top by a pair early
mercedes leading the majors with a 5
65 batting average two and one
two mercedes and your mean tattoos this
ball
oh where is it gonna land bring him
home back to back in the first
welcome to chicago 73.
his second home run of the year
an introduction to the home folks you
mean mercedes got a slider
and took it way back bases loaded
luis robert base it here would make it
really bright i could use a little bit
of that over here
in the year to left on a line and ben
and tendy
madrigal's coming home and the sox have
run number four it's a sac fly for luis
robert
on the first pitch he sees and the socks
are up four nothing
lance lynn now has a four nothing lead
is bell the seventh batter in the order
one and two lance lynn cuts him down
fourth strikeout
seven up seven down for lynn two down
for nikki lopez
tipped into the glove strike three so
one revolution deep
lance lynn has been perfect
nine up nine down for lance so far in
his white sox home debut
nope 2-0
in the air center field roberts coming
in and luis
parks to make the catch for round number
one
[Applause]
this to right field eaton going back
eaton's at the track and adam eaton
makes the catch
to retire the side 12 in a row for lance
lim
kyle zimmer comes into this off just a
great year last year
starting off with a great year this year
but last year 157
era appeared in 16 games just one of
them a start
adam eaton and a breaking ball swing and
a missed good
curveball from kyle zimmer and he
strikes out the first batter he faces
ground ball lopez rolls it to second and
it's in time
that was all he could get on that throw
and it cuts down
danny mendick to end the bottom of the
fourth
south paris will start it against lance
lynn
four-nothing white sox there's a tapper
to first base and this is gonna be the
first base runner lance lynn didn't have
a chance to get over there
and salvador perez gets to first so
the perfect game is over on a squibber
to jose abreu two down in the inning
runners still at first and second and
it'll be up to michael
a taylor why start now
strike three two singles no harm done
you like lance i like him a lot
sixth inning but that's the first ground
out
as lynn continues to keep the ball up in
the zone
and they continue to swing under it
with merrifield first pitch attack to
right
adam eaton for out number two
four-nothing white sox in the sixth ben
intended with two outs
eaton charging and has to play it on a
hop third single given up
by lance lynn so he's been very much in
command
this afternoon and evening
one man on the left side of the infield
and it's johan monkatta
and that will do it lance lynn is
bolting like a brayu running through the
infield four nothing
perez to the mound for a visit before
danny mendick backs
he did and it's a base hit for danny
mendick it was a changeup in the zone
and danny rocked it to left and the
vases are loaded
for eaton up the middle
into center field once home
madrigal's coming no throw six nothing
sucks
the bases are loaded for jose abreu
and what are the chances he would get
another crack at a third grand slam
what's he got for jose well he did
and jose hit it skyward to center field
taylor on the move battling the wind and
no tag from third
from danny mendick two down he's ready
breaking ball monkatta to center
taylor's been busy and that will do it
but the sox get two more runs
royals have two on now and ben and
tendy's gonna back
lance lin is one strike away from at
least an eight inning night
and the fans here are cheering to get
out of this one
keep it scoreless two or two check swing
he went right
yeah here's your answer lance lynn
double figure strikeouts he has just
been marvelous
second time ever in sox history with 10
plus strikeouts in a home opener edwin
jackson was tremendous
10 years ago to a game that you're
pitching
eaton in right one down in the night
it's another broken bat i think danny
mendick
out number two aiming for a shutout and
he's
one out away jorge soler
two outs ninth inning two and two
he struck him out a home
opener complete game shutout
twirled by lance lynn